c'est faire courir moi tu voles andrew
kent
un bébé à sa rage amis je suis un breton
qui est né d'un père marin pêcheur et
d'une mère paysanne
[Musique]
personne ne peut en tous les cas pas
ceux qui n'ont jamais fait peut venir
réclamer des comptes à sur la violence
de la guerre sur les nécessaires
obligations imposées par la hiérarchie
militaire et politique du temps moi
aussi me lever à mon tour pour tenir une
minute de silence ou une quelques
instants de silence au moins pour en
mémoire de tous ceux qui sont tombés des
dizaines de millions d'hommes tombés
dans le monde sous la dictature
communiste
je ne dis pas que les chambres à gaz
n'ont pas existé mais je crois que c'est
un point de détail de l'histoire de la
deuxième guerre mondiale les sidaïques
s'ils voulaient j'emploie ce mot là
c'est un espèce de l'épreuve
durafour crématoire merci de cet aveu je
crois l'inégalité des races oui bien sûr
mais ces bruits elle aussi fait la
beauté offrant une fournée la voile
bonne foi
[Musique]
on dit que vous êtes le ronald reagan
français qu'est ce que vous en pensez
écoutez je pense qu'on fait beaucoup
d'honneur j'établirai dans tous les
domaines la préférence nationale
[Musique]
aulas ah oui qu'est-ce qu'on attend pour
être
[Musique]
c'est illisible bourgeoise girl est une
petite fille bourgeoise voilà
[Musique]
jeudi ni raciste ni facile ni
extrémistes n'ont pas passé le pense une
heure ou une heure avant mais sur ce
sujet là
[Musique]